foreign
[Music]
thank you for coming to my talk
um I'll just get running and rolling
here if you'd like to follow along as I
go through this
you can find the slides on the
conference app for this speaker session
I also just tweeted out the link you can
find that at Mark J Reiki that's i-e-k-e
um but today I'll be introducing work
boots which is a tool and a package for
generating prediction intervals from
tidy model workflows
so I used to be a mechanical engineer so
before I jump into talking about this
tool I want to talk about some other
Niche and interesting tools
um uh that I've seen as a mechanical
engineer
so this
um is something interesting if you look
at it you might not know what it's used
for offhand one of my friends who works
at a B sent this to me this is a pigtail
proof coil it lets Brewers take samples
from these humongous beer tanks safely
this second tool again really
interesting looking what's it used for
off the bat I don't know uh but for
folks who do know this is a wire crimper
and it's very useful for dealing with
large electrical lugs again safely and
efficiently
and this Abomination uh we don't really
have to talk about too much
but one tool that I use often that is
again Niche and specific is this Kreg
Jig on first glance you might not know
what it would be used for it's got this
odd cylinder on one side
but you can see that in a specific
scenario it's a perfect tool for this
job
and that's kind of what I like to think
work of work boots as it is a specific
tool for a specific job
and that specific job is for when you
are building a model
and you would like to generate a
prediction interval but you're using a
model type that on its own only
generates Point predictions
work boots will let you take that model
and generate prediction intervals
so why might you be interested in using
this package
well maybe you're somebody like me again
my name is Mark Ricky I am a senior
consumer experience analyst for Memorial
Hermann health system in Houston Texas
we are a large hospital system in the
Houston area with 17 hospitals 11 of
which are acute care hundreds of clinics
and outpatient facilities servicing
about 30 000 employees
and my small But Mighty team of four uh
handles and Fields requests from all 30
000 employees so to the other team
members who are you know keeping the
fort
together I'm very thankful that they let
me run off to DC
but what we do is we deal with our
patient satisfaction survey data
our job is to administer understand
analyze this data to hopefully improve
our patient satisfaction when they go
through our hospital system
and the majority of the time our
day-to-day involves answering questions
so some of the questions that come up
are ones like this you know we see a
pretty consistent Trend going upwards
um in our patient satisfaction score and
then this drop off in April what's going
on there
if we look at scores across hospitals
you know maybe we're seeing differences
are these real differences or is this
just due to sampling variation
and thirdly we see different response
rates uh depending on if we send invites
out via email or if we send invites out
via text you know which one should we
use
so these are all questions that on their
own giving a point estimate for
you know is a good first step
but to get the full picture we really
need to add in uncertainty
because that will help us separate
signal from noise
so maybe we see by adding in confidence
intervals that in April perhaps there
was a disruption in the survey
distribution workflow and we only sent
out a few surveys that month so this is
really just statistical noise
you know if we look across hospitals
maybe we see a lot of overlap in the
potential uh underlying scores so again
you know nothing to uh be too concerned
about here
but hey if we look at the difference in
response rates these are pretty
significantly different and it's readily
apparent once we add in our uncertainty
intervals and this is something that we
can action around
I think when I say this out loud we all
understand at a base level that point
estimates don't give the full picture
but we really need additional context to
help that point sink through
so this also extends to not just when
I'm answering specific questions but
when I'm answering questions with a
model
so you know what are the drivers of
patient satisfaction
what will our score be how many
responses are we expecting
these are all questions that I can and
have answered with models but again
because I'm always wanting to layer in
uncertainty
I'm really limited to the types of
models that I can use
my problem is that this is me like all
the time
I uh
I see people using like fun and fancy
models like XG boost or like K nearest
neighbors regressors but because of the
work I'm doing I'm really stuck using
plain old LM
so that's where work boots comes into
play this is a package that hopefully
Bridges the gap between simpler models
that let you generate prediction
intervals right out of the bag
and more powerful models that let you
you know get non-linearity and and
complex interactions work boots
hopefully gets the best of both worlds
by letting you generate prediction
intervals while still using your more
powerful models
so let's go into the package itself
and I think one thing we should
do right out the gate is look at where
work boots sits in the model building
timeline if some of you recognize this
slide this is something that I totally
stole from an old Julia silgi
presentation uh that walks through how
you might go from model conception and
idea
to model finalization
so maybe you're starting off on the left
with doing some exploratory analysis
engineering new features and then
fitting tuning and evaluating a set of
models
and perhaps you repeat this a few times
before you finally get to your you know
finalized model
a lot of this is already handled by tidy
models work boots really just comes in
as that last leg of the journey so
you've done all your pre-processing I've
done all your feature engineering you
know all of your hyper parameters are
tuned and now you're ready to answer
that big question that your stakeholder
has been asking you
and part of the reason why it makes
sense that work boots is you know just
this last step is that there are a
couple of checks that you really want to
make sure you're hitting before it makes
sense to use work boots again it's a
really specific tool for a really
specific job
so firstly
you should make sure that the residuals
of your model are normally distributed
this is an assumption that it makes
under the hood
secondly you need to make sure you
actually have enough time to run this
model
um I'm an analyst I wrote this for
myself primarily I'm never really
concerned with putting models into
production
um so depending on the amount of
pre-processing and the size of your data
set work boots could take anywhere
between five and you know 20 minutes to
Output prediction intervals so please do
not deploy this when you need to have
something answer a question in a
fraction of a second
and thirdly and finally most importantly
uh it really makes sense to make sure
that you actually need this more
powerful model that work boots allows
you to use uh what I found a lot of the
time is that good old Plain Jane LM will
you know really uh get you the answers
that you need maybe 80 90 of the time
but if you do find yourself in a
scenario where you are meeting all three
of these checks and you're ready to
start using work boots
how does it actually work
I'm going to gloss over this very
quickly but if you'd like to dig in
deeper into some of the math that's
underlying it you can scan this QR code
that'll take you to a little bit of an
explainer
but at a very high level work boots
takes your training data
generates a whole bunch of bootstrap
resamples
then it fits many models to each of
these resamples or excuse me it fits a
model to each resample so you end up
with many models
thirdly it takes each of these many
models and predicts on new data
so for each observation in your new data
set you have many predictions
and then finally finally it summarizes
all of these with a prediction range
so now that we've checked that we can
use work boots we kind of know what's
going on let's get into actually using
it with some code
so there's three things that we're going
to do first of all work boots Builds on
top of Tidy models so what we'll do is
set up a tidy model workflow
next we'll use work boots to generate
our predictions and then thirdly we'll
use work boots to summarize these
results
there is some great documentation
on Tidy models and how to use it but I
will just set up a very quick workflow
for explanation's sake
so in this case we'll be
using the Palmer Penguins data set for
this example
this is a data set that contains a bunch
of information and characteristics about
penguins from different uh from
different Islands such as their bill
length build depth what species they are
which island they came from and what
we'll be predicting on their body mass
as is best practice for this example
we'll split into a testing and training
data set
so next we'll set up a pretty basic
pre-processing recipe in this case again
uh we'll be predicting each penguin's
body mass based on all of the data
that's available in the data set
and then we'll combine this
pre-processing with a model in a
workflow
in this case using a boosted tree model
for regression which uses XG boost under
the hood as a reminder XG boost can only
generate Point predictions on its own
so now that we have the workflow set up
you know we're done with tiny models now
we can jump into work boots
one of the large Workhorse functions
within the package is this predict boots
function
this is uh going to take the workflow
that we just set up
we'll pass that to predict boots
specify the number of bootstrap
resamples that we'd like to take
and then because we are fitting and
predicting all in one Fell Swoop we're
going to pass both the training data and
the new data that we're going to predict
on in this case this is the Penguin's
test data set
and what this returns is a tibble
uh with nested predictions for each
observation in the test data set so in
this case each row is a penguin in
penguin's test and we have 2 000
estimations of their weight from our
many models that we created
we can summarize this by passing this to
the summarize predictions function this
just returns a median lower and upper
prediction interval range
and just like that we have taken a model
that only generates Point predictions
and returned uh prediction ranges
excuse me prediction intervals
by default work boots and predict boots
will generate prediction intervals
but if we you know so desire we can
change this to generate confidence
intervals by setting interval to
confidence
and just as a reminder of the difference
between the two here's an example
looking at the Ames housing data set
in this case this example is predicting
each home's sale price based on the
first floor square footage on the left
prediction intervals are the range in
which we might expect to find any
individual homes price
and on the right is a example of a
confidence interval which is the range
in which we might expect to find the
model output
uh thirdly and finally in addition to
generating prediction and confidence
intervals work boots allows us to
generate estimations of variable
importance
uh this function is that does this is
very similar to predict boots it takes
the workflow that we've created passes
it to VI booths we specify again the
number of resamples that we'd like to
take and our uh and give it our training
data
and what this returns is
a tibble with nested estimations of
variable importance for each feature in
the model
and what we can see from this example
oh oh sorry I missed a slight uh and
again there's another summarized
function that lets us return a median
lower and upper interval range
we can pass this to summarize importance
to get this output
and what we can see from this example is
that flipper length and whether this
species was you know of the Gen 2
species is pretty important to this XG
boost or this set of XG boost models in
determining each penguin's weight but
there are wide ranges around those
estimations of importance and the other
hand what island to come the penguin
comes from
um is we're pretty confident it's not
very important
so in closing uh my call to action for
you all is to
give work boots a shot
again I think this is a very specific
tool for a very specific job
but if you find yourself in the
situation where you need to generate
prediction intervals and you don't want
to be limited by model type I think work
boots might be the package for you so
thank you I'm happy to take any
questions
um and I've I have some links for
additional reading material that'll uh
if you're interested in digging in
further thank you
[Applause]
[Music]